[Musique]
le losc à deux gammes in waves
ce n'est pas une question de prix à
gagner ou qui a perdu l'épidémie
arrivent par vagues
ce qui arrive en france et peut
également arriver au royaume uni à la
grande différence est que le royaume uni
a vacciné une large partie des groupes
fragiles vulnérables des plus âgés ils
sont protégés
notre différence et notre long
confinement qui a fait baisser le nombre
de cas en france malheureusement là
comme des cas restent élevés car votre
confinement la pâte est stricte et la
vaccination n'a pas non plus été aussi
rapide dans i'm not be enough for speed
aïda pas du tout il faut être prudent a
l'air attentif
ce virus ne respecte pas les frontières
on les démarcations lepreau positif est
que les personnes âgées au royaume uni
sont partiellement immunisés grâce au
vaccin mais il ya encore un long chemin
à parcourir et message au royaume uni et
soyez prudents soyez attentifs
faute de quoi il pourrait y avoir une
nouvelle flambée comme dans l'union
européenne
mais kyle just like des européennes
gagnant deux vaccine campagne has been
trying to prevent c'est vers 9 heures
ils ne savent qu aux dettes grecques si
la campagne vaccinale prévient c'est
prouvé les formes graves et donc la mort
le vaccin est très bon cependant nous ne
serons pas hors de danger
tant que tout le monde ne sera pas hors
de danger nous espérons de vacciner le
monde entier jusqu'à ce qu'un nombre
important de personnes soient vaccinés
dans l'union européenne et dans le monde
nous ne sommes pas hors de danger le
virus peut changer invariants peut
émerger avec des nombreuses
contaminations dans l'union européenne
l'afrique l'inde et caetera et le virus
peut voyager jusqu'au royaume uni s'il
résistait aux vaccins ce serait un
retour à la case départ
il faut être prudent travailler avec la
communauté internationale afin de
s'assurer que l'union européenne
l'afrique l'asie ou l'amérique du sud
souhaite également vaccinés aussi
rapidement que possible
l'union africaine ua a émis nice as
quickly as par seconde
situé à l'est devant ce moment et du
royaume uni une légère pénurie dans
l'approvisionnement
la stratégie est de dispenser leur
seconde dose aux personnes concernées
puis de vacciner les personnes plus
jeunes
lorsque les deux seront disponibles on
ne va pas réduire le vaccin une seule
dose nous recevons de données les
personnes qui n'ont pas encore été
vaccinés
le seront un peu plus tard la bonne
nouvelle avec l'arrivée de plusieurs
nouvelles plateformes vaccinale et qu'il
y aura des deux en surplus il relèverait
des bonnes pratiques de santé publique
de santé mondiale de partager ces doses
les stockés dans des hangars serait
inutile le plus important est de les
partager avec les régions du nord plus
pauvres afin que d'autres gens puissent
également être protégés ce la meilleure
stratégie pour la santé publique et la
santé mondiale
pavlik a global stratégies